Republican Senator Lindsey Graham is on
the Armed Services Committee
he served 33 years in the Air Force Air
Force Reserve and Air National Guard he
is with us from Clemson South Carolina
good morning good morning you heard what
your good friend Senator McCain said
that great leaders do not threaten
unless they are prepared to act do you
believe the United States is prepared to
act oh absolutely
there are two scenarios where we would
go to world North Korea they attack Guam
or some other American interests or our
allies or if they tried to keep
developing a ICBM with a nuclear weapon
on top to hit the homeland we would act
president Trump has basically drawn a
red line saying that he'll never allow
North Korea to have an ICBM missile that
can hit America with the nuclear weapon
on top he's not gonna let that happen
he's not going to contain the threat
he's gonna stop the threat well when you
say that up when president Trump's when
President Trump says that there is at
issue the question of how many people
might die from a retaliation on South
Korea yeah general mattis described it
very well it'd be a horrific war
unfortunately we're headed that way
unless North Korea stops put yourself in
president Trump shoes for a moment where
does your allegiance slide is it isn't
your primary purpose as president United
States to protect the American homeland
from a nuclear weapon attack by a guy
like kim jungeun
my belief is that we're headed that way
unless the world can stop North Korea
he's going to pick homeland defense over
regional stability and he has to for 30
years this has failed this is not a
language problem this is a North Korean
regime trying to get the capability to
strike America the ultimate insurance
policy for regime survivability and no
president should allow this to happen we
failed for 30 years it's time to try
something new senator Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson just landed in Guam and he
was speaking to reporters there he said
our telephone lines remain open he says
this is not an escalation he's the
president Trump was simply trying to
speak in language that Kim jong-un would
understand in terms of that rhetoric
does it seem to you like there's
diplomatic progress well we had
sanctions passed by the UN that were
very tough nikki Haley did a great job
secretary Tillerson is telling North
Korea they will not be a war to change
her regime there will not be a war to
reunify the Korean Peninsula contradict
with the CIA director Mike Pompeo said
when he was out at Aspen where he said
regime change actually is a u.s. goal
well I don't think it's the goal of the
American president to change the regime
it's the goal of the American president
to stop North Korea from having an ICBM
that can hit America with a nuclear
weapon on top he would go to war to
prevent that that's where war would be
likely to occur if they continue to
threaten the homeland
I hope diplomacy work sanctions haven't
worked before maybe they'll work now but
China should have more than we got two
bad options that is to let them get a
missile to hit America or go to war to
stop them China should have two bad
options deal with a nut job in your
backyard or realize that there'll be a
war in your backyard do you think this
was a message to China as well as to
North yes yes and the time for talking
is running out I want to know what South
Korea and Japan think about the
miniaturizing of a weapon I don't want
to trust one Intel report we've learned
from Iraq you need to be cautious but I
do believe Donald Trump will not allow
kim jeonggyun kim jeong-hoon to get a
missile to hit america with a nuclear
weapon on top and as a matter of time to
that capability exist so I hope we can
do this diplomacy and sanctions of war
would be terrible but if there's going
to be a war it's going to be in the
region not here in America well as you
know there already
intelligence reports that say the
miniaturization is not the issue the
issue now is there to protect the
re-entry and the guidance system that
that's the final barrier they have to
pass I don't know the exact nature of
their missile program and I don't think
we have very good eyes and ears on how
far along they are but we know they're
trying and it's a matter of time I'd
like to hear from South Korea and Japan
their Intel services but it's just a
matter of time until they get this
capability when Putin says that you know
he didn't interfere in our election he's
lying when the Ayatollah says he's not
trying to build a nuclear bomb he's
lying when Assad says he didn't use Kim
weapons he's lying this band Kim jong-un
is not lying he's saying that he's going
to build an ICBM with a nuclear weapon
on top to hit America and I don't want
to live for the next 50 years under that
threat and he'll have a hydrogen bomb
one day with a bunch of missiles if we
don't stop him now everything before did
not work I don't want him to get
stronger over time
senator Graham thank you very much